let me welcome all of you to our very
first classic metal class this is a
one-hour session where I'll be doing
some presentation and then we'll open
things up for discussion and Q&A you
notice that I've also got a special
guest here Scott - really I'm going to
tell you about him in just a moment but
before that let me say that what we're
doing here is going to be sort of a at
first at least a monthly thing where
there'll be some sort of presentation
followed by Q&A and discussion about
some sort of topic pertaining to classic
heavy metal and I'll tell you what I
mean by that in just a minute so let me
introduce my my special guest Scott
truly is a good friend and colleague of
mine who have known for a number of
years he is a professional guitarist has
a number of albums he's also done a lot
of studio and gig work as many musicians
like that do you would be surprised by
the people that he's actually played
with but he's also a band leader of his
own and he is a professor at Berklee
School of Music professor of guitar it's
kind of a cool thing to be able to talk
about being a professor it's re
professor philosophy is nice but
professor guitar is even cooler so he's
joining me in part because I want to tap
him here and there about things having
to do with sound and music theory and
some of the history stuff he's a he and
I have you know talked about this many
times
I'm Greg Sandler I think all of you know
me I build myself sometimes as the
heavy-metal philosopher especially when
I let my hair down and this is something
that I've been wanting to do for it for
quite some time it's got and I've talked
about this quite a bit which is to
approach some of the things in something
that we really love classic heavy metal
from a kind of rigorous perspective not
totally rigorous it's not going to be
dried all classroom stuff but we are
going to throw a lot of information at
you and there is a thesis to this so
I'll tell you about that in just a
moment
this session is devoted to classic heavy
metal and as all of them will be and
it's devoted to a particular time frame
what we can call early heavy metal
1972-1974 and I picked those years for a
reason 1974 was a really watershed year
and it's you know most of the experts on
this say that's when heavy metal began
and they usually talk about Black
Sabbath which we're going to talk quite
a lot about in this but you know it
there was a lot of other things going on
in 74 that are really pertinent to the
metal scene and then why 1974 well
because by that time some of the other
later bands are making their debut and
you know I'm thinking in particular
about Judas Priest with Rocka Rolla but
we also have kiss with kiss and we have
a number of other things going on up
until that time you know I could have
picked 75 but 74 is a good stopping
point and there is a kind of narrative
that I'm going to be critiquing here so
I'm gonna lay these cards right down on
the table right away and the narrative
is one that you see some researchers
about heavy metal saying but they also
get this from one of the the big heavy
hitters in the heavy metal scene and
that's Rob Halford the lead singer of
Judas Priest and he the general idea
runs like this heavy metal begins with
Black Sabbath sure there were other
things going on like Led Zeppelin and
deep purple at the time but Black
Sabbath is really the main game in town
and then you know Black Sabbath wasn't
you know received all that well which is
quite true by by the intelligence you
know the music press but they were quite
popular and they labored in the
wilderness you know as these these
persevering heavy metal originators for
years and
Kame Judas Priest now it's a little bit
of a cell surfing narrative what do you
think about it that way but it's become
quite popular and and here's you know I
did a review of Gary Sharpe Young's
metal the definitive guide back in 2012
saying hey this is a problem here and I
was very surprised that same year when
it was either then or 2013 when I saw
Judas Priest on stage and Rob Halford
gave that sort of narrative in a speech
he interrupted he didn't interrupt songs
he was actually getting it between songs
and it was this retrospective thing he's
talking about you know where heavy metal
began and I was like how does he you
know how is he getting people to buy
into this but it's become quite quite
prevalent and I did some polling when
when I had you sign up for this and you
know there are some people who do accept
that narrative but some other people
would say it's really the big three
you know Black Sabbath Led Zeppelin deep
purple all emerging sort of at the same
time others said by a similar proportion
that no there's a lot of other stuff
going on here and so I'm going to talk
about that narrative it's dense so there
is a thesis here and the thesis is that
heavy metal is is a very complex
phenomenon that we understand you might
say retrospectively and there is a band
that is a catalyzer in it and as you
might say first among equals Black
Sabbath but they're not the only game in
town and there definitely was no
wilderness to wander around in between
the times of Black Sabbath Black
Sabbath's emergence and Judas Priest's
emergence if we charted in terms of
their albums and what's going on
so let's launch now into a little bit
more in depth stuff one thing that
people want to do right off the bat
usually is trying to define heavy metal
and that is a
the cool thing to do you know it's
difficult to do with any musical genre
they often bleed into each other so you
know there there's two mistakes I think
people make that we want to try to avoid
from the start one of these is to try to
define a thing by its origin and say
that you know once we've identified the
origin point we know what the thing is
and that really doesn't work for for
musical movements and genres anymore
than it does for other artistic or
creative genres and so you know well we
can talk about particular songs or
groups or albums as being seminal being
essential being catalyst I prefer that a
chemical metaphor their catalyst
precipitates things out of a solution
that are already there in the solution
but the catalyst provides something that
they can they can circle around sort of
like you know when you make rock candy
or when you precipitate something else
out of a solution the other mistake that
I think people sometimes fall into is
trying to provide an exaustive
definition of what heavy metal music
will be in part because you know
definitions of important things are
usually not so cut and dry as we like
them to be and if you think about a
definition is sort of like a circle that
everything that's that's defined he has
to fit into and everything that's not it
in that definition should be outside of
it that's not going to work for heavy
metal what people often do when they try
to have a definition like that is they
take their favorite type of that'd be
metal or their favorite band and they
make them the essence of it and then we
we lose sight of the the broader more
complex story and we also kind of cut
ourselves off from a lot of cool stuff
that that we might otherwise have run
into so what I would propose instead you
know since I've said well these are the
two things to avoid here's two things to
consider and keep in mind is we're
trying to provide some sort of working
definition
heavy metal so one of these is we could
call it the VidCon Stinney in family
definition notion family family
resemblance notion of definition and
this comes from Liberty that can shine
his philosophical investigations he's
not the only person to propose this sort
of thing but it's quite popular in
cultural studies where we're dealing
with complex matters and the idea is
that there's no one single trait that
you can single out that make something
heavy metal instead there's a number of
different connected traits sort of like
the resemblances within a family or if
you like another one of his metaphors if
you have a braided rope there's no one
single strand that's holding it all
together it's rather the the composition
itself and some things can be more
towards the outside and some things can
be more central to it like you know I I
don't think you're going to have heavy
metal without having a vocalist a
bassist a guitarist and a drummer and
sometimes people can have you know - you
know they can they can occupy two of
those roles there's plenty of bassist
who are also singers to take blankey
Wallis for example there's plenty of
people who do double duty in that but
that's that's kind of central to it but
could we find exceptions maybe we might
be able to if we think about it really
hard and but those are going to be
towards the outside of something that's
not going to be a perfect outline circle
but rather almost like a fuzzy field
that gets more and more distinct the
further that we get inside of it and for
early heavy metal Black Sabbath is
really going to be at the center of that
other bands will fit into that as as
well the other thing I would I would say
that really important to keep in mind is
heavy metal was not defined as such as a
movement by the people who were engaged
in producing that movement at the time
it's something that got to find
retrospectively and in many cases there
were bands who actually even though they
can be considered heavy metal resisted
that name and they said we're not a
heavy metal band ac/dc is a prime
example it's arguable whether they are
heavy-metal or not but they certainly
insisted that they weren't even lemme
would say I'm just playing rock and roll
even though Motorhead by the neck you
know late 1970s early eighties is at the
absolute center of the new wave of
British heavy metal right so there's
there's going to be this this you could
say self-conscious community development
and identification that's going on and
that itself is also complex so we want
to keep all of this in mind as we're
we're going through this there is a
interesting discussion later on about
well who actually came up with the term
and and one of the people I'd really
like to turn you on to if you don't know
her already
Donna Weinstein who is just south of
here I believe at University of Chicago
major researcher on the sociology of
heavy metal came out with a book in 91
about heavy metal that is probably one
of the most cited academic sources about
the genre and it's good it's it's it's
good stuff there are some limitations to
it like any other work but she she gets
brought up in a lot of other things and
she's got a piece that in in this volume
heavy metal music in Britain where she
talks about who actually came up with
this this term usually it's attributed
to this guy Lester Bangs right but her
research has shown that it actually was
Mike Saunders in a 1971 review of Lord
Baltimore their debut album and now of
course Saunders and bangs were in touch
with each other
bangs was Saunders editor so and and
Saunders himself did not believe that he
was the first person to start using that
term to talk about that kind of music
consistently until Weinstein showed it
to us and so you know a lot of the you
might say the mythology or the lore
about the movement we have to take with
a bit of a grain of salt and we want to
look at these things quite carefully the
other thing that I do want to say about
about defining heavy metal is that
another thing that makes it difficult to
provide definitions and such
is that metal I won't say broke up but
rather developed into a number of
different subgenres and so if you're
looking at it from the perspective of
say the mid-90s onward and that's where
your consciousness of what heavy metal
is was formed you're probably more
inclined to think in terms of this kind
of metal this kind of metal this kind of
metal this kind of metal and to have
less of a picture of you might say the
coherence of the earlier years the 70s
and the 80s which were themselves you
know a kind of a spectrum and kind of a
mess as well weinstein writing in 1991
really talked about three main genres
she was identifying what she saw as the
core of heavy metal which would include
bands like early rainbow do Iron Maiden
Motorhead and then you know she was
identifying the emerging thrash movement
with its own aesthetic and its own
approach as a definite genre coming up
speed metal and then she talked about
pop metal and/or she also used the word
metal light at that time to talk about
bands like you know poised and to some
degree Motley Crue you know that sort of
the stuff that was coming out of you
know the American setting in large price
I think she would put Def Leppard in
there as well the DEF LEPPARD at that
time and so when we're thinking about
defining you know it sometimes genres
might not fit neatly into the super John
of heavy metal so we're going to focus
in this session on you know talking
about really heavy mouths we're not
talking about death metal we're not
talking about black metal we're not
talking about you know later thrash or
anything like that we're talking about
what made what made for this is self
conscious movement in the early 70s and
here's where I want to tap scout a bit
you know if we think about what we
identify as as metal so there's two
things I want to do one thing and I'll
do this with Scott is to talk about some
of the central features the other thing
I want to point out is that the notion
of what
as metal has changed over time so if you
if you think about a band like Judas
Priest for example and you listen to you
know early albums you know RocknRolla
sad wings of Destiny sin after sin and
then you go from that and you jump into
the you know early 80s like defenders of
the faith or well let alone turbo
alright and then you listen to later
stuff big differences big differences in
the sound big differences in what's
going on in the music there are some
things that do remain the same it's
identically identifiably the same band
but there there is a different way in
which the guitars are being distorted or
just over driven there's a different
kind of bass playing and Ian Hills Park
in say defenders of the faith and
screaming for vengeance and of course
turbo worry is doing much more just no
kind of stuff then there is insane after
sin or sand rings of Destiny so we're
you know we've got that to keep in mind
and if we talk about you know what are
some of the key traits I think that we
can say that some of the the really
identifying aspects of metal especially
early metal would be the sound in terms
of instrumentality and this is where I'm
gonna turn things over to Scott and just
just a minute for a little bit the
lyrical themes there's a number of
different lyrical themes that we can
identify ranging from you know the
abandonment of utopia and talking more
about dystopia fantasy military themes
horror partying is another baby
and how great it is to party yeah you
know there's also love songs of a sort
and all sorts of other things
then there's we could say the look in
the lifestyle which again changes over
time as well but but it you know it
she's the sort of identity by say the
the mid 70s and early 80s and then you
know something that Donna Weinstein has
identified she talks about metal as
being a particularly masculine type
music which doesn't mean that women
can't participate in and/or enjoy it but
that and she also says is a certain kind
of masculinity it's not it's not just
any sort another thing that we can also
say is that that metal for the most part
especially in the area that we're
talking about is not particularly
politically engaged and it's sort of a
withdraw withdrawal from some of the
things were happening in the 1960s in
part because they said most didn't
really actually make that big of a
difference we have to focus on our own
thing so what I think the musicality is
probably the most important thing so I'm
going to turn this over to Scotford for
a little bit Scott what would you say
are like some of the most identifying
traits that you would say ties a Black
Sabbath and deep purple and you know
even up to bands like Judas Priest and
kiss and Montrose together you know
there's there's three basic
characteristics I talked about with
musicians and you've touched upon so at
the core if I take three of them its
sound and that could be a particular
person's tone it could be the volume it
could be you know like whatever the
whatever is coming out of your speakers
that you can identify oh that guitar is
very distorted
that's a cranked Marshall so that's an
example of sound the next thing is pitch
organization so pitch you so they tended
to use power cords for example and not
like these like big ringing cords but
there's a lot in preach organization so
you can kind of tell from well we have
the sound we have the picture
organization and then rhythm is a big
one so you know let's take something
that's let's take how eighth notes might
be played in jazz right or R&B where it
kind of swings and swing I don't mean
like if there's any musicians here you
know in contraband they say swingers dot
dot dot dot but it's not swing is a feel
just like rock and roll's a feel so
we're [ __ ] are be like one so one two
three four one two three rock and roll's
very one two three four so the one is
so rhythm is an important thing the the
pitches they use now these of course can
bleed over as you said I really love
what you said about the the the the
family definition right so the things
that but like you know so let me address
first these three because you've brought
up so many great points about other
things like lifestyle like vocal content
um you know I've always thought that
Dick Dale you know the surf guitarist as
far as sound he was a pioneer in the
early 60s he went to leo fender and said
you have these 30 watt amps I went a
hundred watt amp so Dick Dale would if
you went to a dick dale show which you
know guys like tony iommi
they were all fans because they go in
it's louder than they've ever heard it
so here's the sonic part of him turning
up the reverb playing surf music with
Middle Eastern scales and going wow that
hit me here like I could feel the bass
the guitar my ears are ringing for days
whatever it is so you know that actually
I think you're you're tapping into
something there that is identifiably
central to two heavy metal and not
unique to it but there is a you might
say emotional response that comes a
bodily response to the sort of music and
it can come it doesn't have to be
necessarily distorted guitars it could
be over driven guitars or as we're going
to talk about the bed acadia to be you
know clean guitar but with the right
sort of bass behind it right or you know
like when I'm listening to things I'm
always listening for the bass and seeing
what the bassist is doing with the lines
and how it's fitting in with the drums
and the the musician and sometimes the
organ but also that that that responds
to just like sheer let's call it
magnitude you mentioned things getting
louder and that is part of the story of
the lead-up to heavy metal things
getting louder and louder and louder and
reaching a certain point where you can
say this is a heavy sound what what
makes for that heaviness
well volume for one thing I mean
you know the credit Jim Marshall you
know that with Marshall amps for anybody
knows like in the 70s everybody had to
have a Marshall 100 watt cranked all the
way up and you know that's part of the
impact in the emotion of it if you go to
those shows the message was delivered
loud and clear but you know but look at
Jimi Hendrix was doing that and you know
yeah it's pretty since 64 1954 25 June
10th a proto metal and to a lot a lot of
these early people are listening to them
you know we're gonna talk about this in
a bit the founder of the flower
traveling band bring essentially brings
heavy metal to Japan precisely because
he wants to capture that jimi hendrix
sound that he transforms it at the
process that's a good point yeah and so
you know if you listen to Hendrix tunes
even purple haze you know that intro at
all huh well I mean that's that's
aggressive I mean it's yeah right it
sounds near that's contestant so you
know he's being a rebel you know I think
you know in a sense that he was
reinventing so but something I want to
mention that you didn't have on your
list that I'm curious your take on is
there's the old saying you know when you
hear it right so so if I if I pick up a
guitar and start playing swing jazz
lines or something like it so do you
might say that sounds really jazzy well
why does it sound Jesse I don't know it
just does or you know I play a band
nobody's heard but it's clearly heavy
metal but maybe they can't define it but
they know it when they hear it so that
is it that's that's the point we can't
quantify yeah so but we're trying to
right we're trying to say well one of
these things didn't have in common but I
think we're talking 72 74 some things I
want to address that you said that were
interesting is they did stay away from
politics early on right you know it's
kind of out war was about fantasy yeah I
mean you could say that that there's a
critical aspect to some songs you know
interestingly a Black Sabbath's second
album was supposed to be titled
title is supposed to be war pics which
have been a lot more of a explicit
critique of you know the Vietnam War and
militarism than calling a paranoid was a
paranoia is an individualistic kind of
thing right yeah and and you know you
can say that there there is some
politics there but it's more of a
politics of their belly Asmus than a
constructive like let's all vote
together and we'll change the world in
this way are there there are some things
there are there are themes about people
transforming the world in wonderful ways
but they often tend to be framed in
fantasy stuff you don't think about your
Riya heaps the wizard right there's some
very clear 1960s kind of utopianism
stuff there it's debatable but whether
that song is actually a metal song the
way that's a bird praise but right you
know it's the wizard who is gonna solve
the problem right that's madam not all
the people coming together something
like that I would also say like the lot
of the content is I grew up in high
school I think a lot of us outcasts
referred to it because it was about the
underdog you know yeah if we look at
Twisted Sister we're not gonna take it
right look what was happening 80s was
about the outcast was bullied and and
kind of beat up in them getting their
revenge for again your moment in the Sun
or it's kind of like you would listen to
these records ago these guys understand
me and then we'd be the guys with the
jean jackets and the rush and all the
the badges on are things going you know
this is my music you you don't accept me
but you know Iron Maiden or who you know
or whoever else accepts me I just want
to go back to something really
interesting about a commentary so like
take a band like Blue Oyster Cult who
was definitely early heavy metal band
yeah they call them the thinking man's
heavy metal right it's been yeah they've
been called that and I you know I think
mainly because their riffs were so
clever and they were they weren't
diatonic and they really challenged kind
of your ear and and it wasn't like you
know paranoid is a straight up tune yeah
but Blue Oyster Cult would right
you know almost Prague s-type taught
students in the early well you know so
that's that's another good thing to
bring up you know that we have is this
sort of sphere let's call it a classic
metal and there's some things that are
closer to the center like Black Sabbath
and you know other things that are
further out and and when they get
further out it's usually because they're
leaning more towards another
identifiable genre so we can talk about
prog rock right and you know there there
is to a lot of early metal there is big
prog elements you know as a matter of
fact you know you can see that in deep
purple that was I think one of the
things that that kind of upset Ritchie
Blackmore it wasn't just I don't think
it was just the funk stuff I think he
also didn't like where the other stuff
was going and I know you know we've
talked a lot about black form that we
might do that a bit more here but so
they don't know we can talk about prog
rock we can talk about you know some
things being more bluesy we can talk
about some things being more you know
are they really heavy metal or they
really just hard rock you know where the
division line between that it's often
difficult to to say and and again many
of these these things are categories
that the reimpose later on on hearing
the music right and some of it is going
to be subjective as I was doing research
for this there were some bands and I was
like I better check these out because
people talk about that was being early
metal and then you listen to their
discography and you're like this is cool
stuff but an ain't metal like atomic
rooster for example and that's and
that's the x-factor that's you go and
you'll know when you hear it yeah and
that probably requires having heard and
assimilated a lot of similar stuff over
over time and it might actually help
they might what do you think it does it
help to have played it at least at an
amateur level to be able to make that
judgement or is it just enough to be a
fan who listens quite a bit you know the
fan of us is quite a bit like I said
before is the one that's got the
emotional attachment like you know for
me I was the outcast I was bullied but
you know
my early scorpions records you know
understood you know not always just
lyrically but you know sonically and
that was the first thing I said sound
yeah but make a distinction since we're
talking about deep purple Led Zeppelin
Black Sabbath as the early British
people that came in right yeah although
actually this is a good segue to talking
about why 1970 was such an important
year so you know when we think about the
big 3d purple Black Sabbath and and Led
Zeppelin they all did something in 1970
each of them brought out an album Black
Sabbath actually brought out two and
Black Sabbath was earliest to the game
with Black Sabbath in 19 in February of
1970 but that doesn't mean that you know
somehow heavy metal emerged on scene at
that time because deep purple and Uriah
Heep who by the way we're playing in
studios next to each other during that
time came out in June with deep purple
and rock and very very heavy very humble
do their lingo that they they like Black
Sabbath comes out with paranoid in
September Led Zeppelin comes out with
Led Zeppelin 3 which has some things
that can be called metal on I mean even
when Zeppelin 2 has some songs that we
could think it retrospectively identify
as that but in the same month UFO comes
out with UFO one which has stuff that's
clearly metal in it and in America
certainly we're in Baltimore in December
is going to come out with Kingdom Come
and interestingly they tour with Black
Sabbath they they're viewed as like
close enough sonically it's a Black
Sabbath that it makes sense when Black
Sabbath is in the States for them to
tour with them so we've got a lot of
things going on by that time the Oyster
Cult is together and playing in clubs
Bungie is is almost ready to start
releasing things there's another Scots
band iron claw when you listen to them
clearly heavy metal that that's that's
playing stuff flour travelin band in in
Japan
the Scorpions are ok they're a bit more
jazzy at the start but they are together
and playing stuff Alice Cooper Amboy
Dukes who Ted Nugent is going to come
out of are doing things that are if we
want to consider heavy metal able if you
want to say that heavy metal can
incorporate things where it's it's a
hard guitar sound then I think that we
can say they're lurching towards heavy
metal I would say that the first really
metal albums by say Amboy Dukes are in
you know 73 and 74 and Alice Cooper I
would say 72 at school's out but they're
they're moving at them and that's an
early anthem yeah exactly and so so
we've got all these things happening in
1970 a number of different albums from a
number of different British bands and
one American band that unfortunately
didn't make it
Sorey Baltimore and so you know it's not
as if Black Sabbath is emerging as
something totally unknown unseen with no
[Music]
similarities as a matter of fact there's
a lot of similarities to what's going on
with these other bands and they're
they're listening to each other and
touring another thing I'll point out too
is that black sabbath is is kind of a
nexus in another way so not just that
people were listening to tony aomi
is going to start producing other
people's stuff and he's he does that by
1973 he's already scouting other bands
and you know looking at their things and
Roger Bain who produced the early Black
Sabbath so who else does he produce
Bungie is coming out of 1971 he also
produces Rocka Rolla by Judas Priest now
according to Judas pretty screwed it up
decide exactly but you know and Judas
Priest is worth mentioning too because
they were already touring around and
playing and coming up with a lot of the
things that are going to go into not
just rock the Wallow but also sad rings
and deaths
there were songs like the Ripper that
didn't make it onto RocknRolla precisely
because of Roderick being where they
could have come out a little bit earlier
there is a bit of a you know there's a
difference and there's a development
going on if you listen to Rob Halfords
demos with Judas Priest early on where
they're playing some of Judas Priest
early stuff like for example whiskey
woman which will get turned into the
song victim of changes it doesn't quite
sound metal and yet it's there's there's
some things where it's still more
indebted to the previous kinds of sounds
right and it doesn't have as much of a
hard edge but it does actually have
cooler bassline some respect
go ahead I was going to say I I've just
been reading some cool comments over
here and a distinction I was gonna make
just to back up a little yeah we're
talking about classical influence and
this is what I was gonna make a
distinction of so take deep purple
scorpions versus Black Sabbath now black
definitely Tony LME's sticks to a
heavier sounding bluesy sound mm-hmm but
you hear Blackmore and Lily John Roth
and there's something more going in
there and somebody's pointed this out
that it's not necessarily gas but like
these in England it was common for the
least
I guess the Royal Albert Hall in England
since the 1800s says had a show a night
every night so it was not uncommon for
them to go hear orchestras so you know
Blackmore would go here Bach and hear
all the stuff and you hear although he's
very bluesy bass you know we hear these
cool little progressions that sound like
Bach progressions that he's outlining in
his interludes yeah well he also has
John Moore of reinforcing that and he
has learned a huge classical influence
you know and and they were pioneers in
that sense because you know no matter
what Yngwie Malmsteen says you know the
ketubah guys for him would Jimmy
Rick's and and Blackmore well just out
of curiosity what does Yngwie Malmsteen
saying since we're doing a little bit of
debunking of narratives here it depends
on his day you know like there was that
thing one year round saying now he was
just a blues guy he goes I owe nothing
to ritchie blackmore but then if it's a
year later and he's in a different mood
he'll say oh yeah no I knew every
Blackmore solo I learned everything
deep purple was my band interesting but
so there there's this sub-genre that we
call now is called European metal and
now again opions that would be deep
purple that European metal like Michael
Schenker you know somebody else who
really stressed how important deep
purple was for him in his biography
autobiography is Bruce Dickinson he
talks about you know got his Black
Sabbath you know central for it well
yeah I like them but I really really was
into deep purple and I was really into
Gillan he was the person I modeled
myself after many of the counts that you
know when they actually met and you know
how he was so you know starstruck and he
that was what he took as being central
for him yeah okay
I mean I'm part of what this points us
towards is in when we think about early
heavy metal we again we should still
think of Sabbath as like first among
equals right but we should almost think
about it like a constellation rather
than just like one central star that
everything else is orbiting around and
the stars are moving and they're growing
you know over time and gradually more
and more of them are emerging some of
them are going out unfortunately but
they're still there so long as we can
still play their catalog right so even
though certain Lord Baltimore fizzled
out in part because they just didn't
have some of the capacities that some of
the other bands did yeah a lot of
contingencies here you know people could
still be listening to them so that's
some of the other really heavy metal
bands mentioned listening to like you
know budgie
UFO Black Sabbath sir Lord Baltimore's
as ornaments great example this would be
pentagram who I was talking about this
with Andy just before the the shows we
were listening to some pentagram stuff
from 1973 and I asked her when do you
think this was from she was like I don't
know maybe 77 I was like this this
actually sounds like it could be from
like 1980 you know in terms of the
musical development and I was like this
is from 73 imagine if these guys who
didn't put out an album until 85 imagine
if they had had the producers and Scouts
and people like that ready to snatch
them up
what a massive impact they could have
had on the metal scene as it was
developing but because they were from
Alexandria Virginia that just that was
not there you know even the bands that
were like making it if we want to think
about you know who was who was
contributing on the American scene you
could say there's like a East Coast
Nexus right which includes New York City
and Boston and Long Island with no
Oyster Cult there's there's quite a few
bands coming out of their kiss right
moister cults who else we have I mean if
you kind of Philly bang is coming out of
there while listening to Aerosmith of
course is coming out of Boston and then
we have a kind of midwest nexus with
Granicus and cleveland Alice Cooper
coming out of Detroit and the amway
dukes and Ted Nugent first in Chicago
and then in Detroit so there's that and
then the only other major places is
California and the big band coming out
of there in the early 70s is Montrose
right that's Annie Hagar
all right motifs great yeah and and and
I should mention too Montrose is coming
out you know Ronnie Montrose comes out
of Edgar winters band so that that's a
proto metal band a lot of these things
have some-some antecedents to them but I
think that on the American scene there
there aren't that many places for reverb
and so sort of like camp
and latch on to there isn't as much of a
petri dish for them to use except in
some of these places like the Detroit
you know Cleveland area in the you know
New York kind of kind of Nexus which
would including Jersey and and all the
way up to Boston I mean what do you what
do you think about that historically is
that makes sense er yeah I mean what you
know when I was thinking about this like
we're talking about the big three in
1970 like the British bands yeah and you
know that I should mention to the
British bands there's a going back and
forth with Germany - oh god yeah the
scorpions
yeah one and scorpions you know are able
to lose well they don't lose they have
the loss inflicted on them by touring
with UFO right Michael schechner gets
the offer to go with the bigger more
experienced band but there were there
was a lot of British bands going to
Germany and playing there I mean this
goes all the way back to the Beatles
right in their time there's there's this
back and forth sort of
cross-fertilization you could say well
let me actually you know this is great
that you mentioned the Beatles to kind
of answer your question if you think
about it rock bands didn't start till
February of 1964 when the Beatles hit
hit ed Sullivan before then you know
there was Elvis there was but there
wasn't Rock and Roll since until 1964
I mean the word bands doing it so that
do you mean like there's there's no real
movement or there's no movement okay so
if you ask 90% of guitarists in their
you know late 50s 60s Steve Lukather or
whatever they say what started Beatles
1964 that's when I knew I wanted so to
play and then all of it like Joe Walsh
says right after that there were no rock
bands but all of a sudden everybody had
a band in their garage and that's where
these being have started coming up with
but things historically it's 2020 now
take 64 as the arguably the movement
starts for the rock band not that they
never existed but the Beatles you know
started all this now we're talking about
Alice Cooper four years later in 68 yeah
oh we're talking about you know I mean
64th - now I mean we're talking about
50-plus years into
control these bands have come up with
this this kind of radical sound in six
years that was yeah I think we were
talking about that a while back in one
of our chat sessions right how
compressed the time is when we start
looking at it how many things are like
coming together in the right way and
again this goes against the sort of like
it was just Black Sabbath and then Judas
Priest sort of like these two nodes you
know heroic kind of kind of narrative
instead there's so much in the air and a
lot of that you know we should mention a
lot of that is contributed by these
proto metal bands that some people would
like to read as metal but but they're
not actually like say cream and Jimi
Hendrix why and well it's like a
download shooter yeah yeah and there's
there's a few bands to that sort of got
grandfathered in that probably shouldn't
count as metal like hawk would you know
I don't think that Hawk wins master the
universe is metal it's a great song same
with silver machine but and let me comes
out of Hawkwind right so there's this
great apprentice thing that's taking
place there but I you know I don't think
that they're actually metal you know
yeah I mean you know I not to like
totally jump off something but I did
want to get an idea earlier about you
mentioned one of the things about saw
lyric content yeah and one of the things
I think heavy metal did is we were
coming from the 60s the flat flower
chair up child era where Woodstock
happened and people were glorifying drug
use in the Haight Ashbury and in San
Francisco and everything was free love
I'll slave some theory right but but but
you know there was this whole movement
of the flower child movement now in 1971
was Blue Oyster cult's first album now
bands like this started to change the
tone so the last days of May if
anybody's heard that from the first boy
circles album is the first song I ever
remember being written that says this
isn't safe people are dying from drug
overdoses people are killing their
friends by doing too much drug selling
it
and it's a beautiful song but you know
that's the first song it's like okay
it's over
it's 1971 two years ago was the Summer
of Love yeah no longer and we what was
the one with thumb I mean I'd say
there's even a sort of ambivalence see
about you know drugs in sweetleaf right
oh actually you know what a really good
point and you know we've got other drug
songs like speed King with the purple
and you know and and I think you're
right there is a there's a different
different there's a different I don't
want to say environment there's
different ethics to it there's a
different way of looking at things
Ravenwood amazi suicide solution
remember that big if you're old enough
to remember he got they tried to sue him
because a kid drank himself to death
then the song was about how dangerous it
is cuz he was an alcoholic and you know
he was writing this song and saying hey
everybody this is big this and we could
think about you know
Judas Priest victim of changes right
it's about a whiskey drinking woman and
a terrible end you know but let's let's
I know that we're a little bit off time
when it comes to this I do want to wrap
up our sort of presentation and start
answering some of these questions so I
so what I what I want to say to kind of
bring it to a close is when we look at
this period from 1970 to 1974 what we
see instead of just you know one main
band and then another main band or a big
three and then a whole bunch of you know
other things are a really rich set of
musical innovations and continuities
that are taking place a lot of these
bands are connected with each other
listening to each other and you know are
they actually calling themselves heavy
metal at the time no but they will
become what is the core of really heavy
metal and the stuff that's going to get
you know passed around on tapes later on
in the late 70s and early 80's the sort
if you like this you listen to this
right and if we look at the bands that
are being that are coming on the scene
say from like 77 through 83 a lot of
them are drawing on these earlier bands
for inspiration I mean think about Iron
Maiden arguably one of the most
successful metal bands that actually
remain metal throughout their their
career if it wasn't for deep purple and
it wasn't for actually some of these
some of these other more obscure bands
where they cover on pieces there
wouldn't have been ironed maintenance
Dean Harris tells you that you know
quite explicitly so that's that's the
main thesis that we're trying to get
across now we should actually start
answering people's questions and and
I'll read them aloud but if people want
to unmute they can also ask questions
let me start with the first Oso Andy
says that she's always felt there's a
melodic musical connection between the
heavy sounds of metal of the escalating
sounds and frenzied jazz so this is for
you Scott do you think that metal and
jazz are more aligned than metal and
classic rock in some ways and I
shouldn't mention that Scott not only is
a metal guitarist he's also a jazz
guitarist so perfect for answer
everything R&B you know that's a great
point because let's go to the sonic
thing we talked about sound as being one
of the things if you listen to like the
last few Coltrane albums the John
Coltrane downs or the McCoy Tyner album
time for not time for Tyner that's a
good one but the real McCoy when I was a
rock player exclusively in high school I
heard Coltrane and to me it was like if
you you know you put the vinyl on you
turn it up Elvin Jonas Jones's crashing
the drums right and they have an Elvin
wasn't me it's on you know the Jimi
Hendrix Experience if you listen to how
they interact and so I would say
sonically yeah the stuff people think
that don't know jazz they think it's
like this background music you hear it
but no no you listen to Eric Dolphy and
if you listen to those those are hard to
listen to because it's it's loud and
he's playing he's not playing as we'd
not like to hear scales that are
comfortable he's really pushing our
making us uncomfortable with the sounds
pushing it forward I mean jazz is
breathing so by the time the sixties hit
you turned out those jazz records they
were all listening to that stuff so Andy
I think is it closer to classical
sonically yes but you know I don't know
any metal classic metal guitars that are
playing jazz type lines like they listen
to Wes Montgomery they listened to Jim
Paul but they didn't their chords didn't
reflect that but sonically they did
reflect Coltrane I mean even the doors
whose a classic rock band I would
consider they they talked about well you
know when when Coltrane did my favorite
things let's do something like that
where we have this one chord vamp and
try to expand it I mean of course they
didn't have the the know how to express
themselves that Coltrane did but they
tried yeah so from a sonic standpoint
that that's a really clever question
because from a sonic standpoint I would
say people like late Coltrane like you
know a Love Supreme if you've ever heard
that um put that on and not the mp3 get
the record or the CD and crank it and
you like the mp3 is just like I always
say mp3s is like taking the moan at
least it's taking a picture of it
photocopying it like 30 times it's still
the Mona Lisa but it's not the details
not there yeah okay Mona I mean the Mona
Lisa is kind of a tough thing to
actually get to see if you go to the
Louvre right you gotta like shove your
way through the whole crowd I mean it's
kind of a good metaphor for thinking
about like getting getting up close to
the stage and at a concert in the old
days right now there's a there's a
follow up here with Mark and
Kennedy mark says what about the
connection with classic symphonic music
to heavy metal
a lot of the over-the-top elements of
metal reflect composers such as
Tchaikovsky and his canons and then
Kevin follows up with the thing with
Bach that's really intriguing its
composers such as Bach were alive today
there's a good argument they'd be
writing what we call metal and and I
want before I turn this over to Scott
who knows much more about this I want to
say well that Bach would be called
Rudolf Schenker one of one of the best
you know metal songwriters out there I
would say and somebody who very
deliberately he's talked about this in
interviews has said I'm not interested
in being a lead guitarist that's why I
had people like you know back in the day
well first his brother and then Julia
John Roth and then Matthias jobs right
those were the guys who are coming in to
do the great solos and all that we're
all focused on the songwriting itself
and that's you know you think about the
scorpions stuff put aside you know
Lonesome Dove which is kind of a weird
album there's some metal stuff on there
but but a lot of it isn't
and then everything from like say 74 to
84 right everything from fly to the
rainbow up to love at first sting
arguably even savage amusement just song
after song after Swan a really really
great great song writing and and I think
that you know I'm not saying he's Bach
or reincarnated everything like no but I
obviously it's not as a complexes by but
but there's something to be said go
ahead Scott yellow mark this is an
amazing question and really insightful
so aside from jazz yeah the connection
between symphonic music so um I think
you know there's a more of an open - in
the 60s like you saw Miles Davis and
Joni Mitchell hanging out Miles Davis's
favorite guitarist was Jimi Hendrix not
a jazz guitarist so I think in the same
respect a lot of these people were
listening to composers and so but when
you listen to symphonic music you don't
have to necessarily be able to analyze
it to hear the layering okay
we start here but then this part gets
really kind of bold but you know I'll
throw a composer maybe you should check
out who invented a lot of stuff as
karl-heinz Stockhausen who's who's a
German guy he and the deal stole that
backward tape thing from him he he was
he wrote the first electronic music
piece 1955 but he was into sonic sound
and stuff and a lot of these metal guys
were looking at how he did things
symphonic li right so you're correct
about that
try cough ski on you know that it's
great I don't know deliberately who took
what but if you hear the compositions
like we were talking more of the more of
the prog stuff well I think it stuff
comes from okay this is a this is a 15
minute piece with three movements and
but it's the same piece and I think even
we can get into like non metal bands
like Genesis who took their cues from
this kind of he listened to the records
and they would absorb it into their
scheme somehow so mark that is an
absolutely valid great thing in the
follow up with Bach now box a great one
because definitely Blackmore his
progressions and even you know angling
who stole them the progressions were
Bach progressions that they were
outlining with arpeggios themselves
directly from Bach's violin sonatas so I
think I think you're right I think this
stuff that you know Bach died in 1750
and he didn't really create anything he
just mastered the Baroque style so he
it's perfect music Bach is always
perfect music so I think they were all
gravitated towards these single lines
that defined harmony which you hear in
deep purple which you hear in Michael
Schenker and UFO and it's like to rock
players that never listened to Bach or
symphonic music it was kind of like
brand-new although it existed centuries
ago so I mean that's a very interesting
thing to say it almost has metaphysical
implications like there's some musical
as you put them lines out there almost
you know sort of just pre-existing and
people latch onto them and then find
ways
you perfect them across genres of music
right Carl has a follow up about Bach he
says pok pok was a church organist look
at the composers who have been around in
more recent years and who are around
today Rhys Chatham Glenn Branca and at
least with their guitar symphonies from
masses and electric guitars
none of that would be considered metal I
think the classical influence is there
but I'm trying to think of some solid
example of metal influence on a
contemporary classical composer I'm sure
it must exist but as someone who spends
huge amounts of time with contemporary
classical music I'm not sure it's a
two-way street that's probably right I
think that I'm actually going to tell a
funny story about that coming from my
youth in the eighties I was you know I
was not just a metalhead but also kind
of screw up and and for a while I was a
ward of the court and and live you know
living in this juvenile detention
facility and they would take us out on
field trips and there was all like
troubled kids some of whom were really
really problematic and I remember there
was this girl on the field trip and she
was she was she was talking about how
she was all into classical and stuff
like that and I knew enough about music
at that time to know that there were
these connections between heavy metal
and classical and you know I had long
hair at the time and I used to wear band
shirts and stuff like oh yeah yeah and
so so I started telling her about this
and she looked at me and she she said
you know who rattled your cage with the
implication being that you know I was
just a stupid ape you know and heavy
metal was this lower type of music and
then classical was the the better sort
right for the elite people and I was
gonna make any entrance man I was just
trying to have a discussion you know and
I think that there's there's there's
probably a lot of that sort of thing
writ large out there I think I mean from
the very beginning the music critics
were usually against any bands that were
considered that they got called metal
and Black Sabbath got panned right now
the more prior
bands music critics tended to like them
but the less pride and the more like
distinctively mentally were the more the
stupider and less refined they thought
you were sigh it wouldn't surprise me
that there's very little impact on
contemporary classical music you know
coming from metal what do you think
Scott well I want to address the first
part of it the church church organist
now the first thing I think of it is
yeah if you think of those those those
Bach pieces on church organ look at the
intro to stone cold right the rain look
I do would start with mr. Crawley a lot
of you know Jon Lord stuff and a lot of
the stuff in your I I hate you know and
so let me let me read the end of this
because I want to get this right because
this is a really you've got some bright
people on this man contemporary
classical composer
I think classical influence is in there
none of the world would ever be
considered metal I think classical
influences there but I'm trying to think
of some solid examples metal influence
on contemporary classical well you know
ok die foo Jakari who I'm starting to
work with he's a contemporary classical
composer from Japan but he he's at the
Royal Academy and in London but you know
that's a really insightful question
because he comes to me and he says I
have this piece and I said oh should I
pull out my acoustic guitar or my nylon
string he said no he was what makes
sounds what sounds exhibits in 2020 I go
well what do you want he goes put
distortion on put so these composers now
are recognizing that sounds have
developed technologies developed since
the 16th 17th 18th century 20th century
and so he's invited me to crank crank of
Marshall and I played something home
round he goes that's it
but there's a string quartet and it's
all this stuff and um yeah I really
think that you know as far as you know
the cats out of the bag
we're in 2020 and even classical
composers have heard rock music on the
radio and these are sounds that they
think about use
and so dye came to me about that exact
thing and I was shocked and he's like
what effects do you have and I said well
this does this he goes just put in the
kitchen sink and I'll tell you what I
like so um yeah actually the progress of
rock music even I don't know about funk
because there's a time thing there but
sonically um at least a die-in Sakamoto
and all these new composers are really
gravitating towards what can you give me
that this new sound they don't want it
to sound like human they don't want it
to sound like Bartok you know that was
pitch organization like we heard before
right so the organizer they're picked
he's different with the same Orchestra
what I think Carl is pointing out it was
well the sounds changed so the or they
don't want to use the orchestra the
pitch organization has already been done
to death now let's bring in the sonic
and that's what the new composers were
jumping hmm here's here's a line that's
coming from Marc and then followed up by
Stephen so Marc says and I think there's
really something to this I think a lot
of the charm of really heavy metal is
that the genre hadn't yet codified
itself so you have these different bands
and musicians exploring these very often
strange sonic landscapes trying to
search out this new style of music
that's why in my own mind I draw a
distinction between metal bands and
bands that have metal songs Led Zeppelin
being an example of the latter but even
some of the more directly metal early
bands do some interesting things
musically that I wish leaner bands had
been more willing to take further and
then Stephen says I agree about the
diversity of early metal what makes it
so interesting from a retrospective
standpoint is you can listen to a number
of bands who might not necessarily sound
alike may not even some metal to more
modern desensitized ears but you can
pick up pieces from each of them that
led to the building of heavy metal as a
genre today you can listen to in rock
and hear the foundations for thrash you
can hear you write heat the rainbow and
hear the foundations for Halloween and
black Guardian etc that's why at least
in my opinion you can't ignore all the
bands between Sabbath and Priest because
you're missing half a story of metal
without these early bands
I think that's that's completely
and so there's two things there there's
they like leading to the later stuff and
then there's the like experimenting
around I mean you think about like you
know Black Sabbath has all this great
stuff and they also have you know
changes you know what's that do it out
there you know and it but it's a good
song you know and they they usually have
found one you know they could sneak
something in and it's not like you know
the later power ballad right which
becomes its own genre romantic stuff yep
what you know there the other is a lot
of their there a lot of things were like
you know I mentioned atomic rooster so
and so as we were listening to them as I
was preparing for this I was like well I
gotta see if they really are metal and
the conclusion we came to is they're not
metal they're really cool the stuff
they're doing is great love the base
work but it's it's not metal as such but
I can see how like a lot of the early
metal people would say oh this is this
influenced us you know especially the
more base where I entered the band was
because in a lot of cases the guitars
are absolutely central you know one
thing definitive of metal is riff heavy
stuff but you also mean that the bass
doing more than just you know eighth
notes the roots right there are a few
exceptions like cliff Williams who's
cool with doing that and ac/dc but for
the most part and that's all that's
going on you got a problem right
and so I there's these two sides to it
the influence side that they're bringing
out and then the experimentation sign so
what do you what do you think it dropped
that Scott well I love the point about
experimenting and well you know as we
said earlier a psychedelic music kind of
was the precursor yeah and psychedelic
was all about let's let's see what
happens yeah we have new effects of the
time and it's kind of like well I can
get feedback like this or what if I drop
ping-pong balls on my guitar or you know
that kind of experimentation I mean you
have to remember these early bands had
nothing to go on I mean right now if I
started a heavy metal band well I'd have
50 years of heavy metal to draw on
these people had nothing and it was just
they were just getting together in a
room going how does that sound well what
if I did this one what was that you did
I don't know my guitar fed back you know
or so I think the point about you know
the songwriting I mean to come up with
something new I mean this is it's less
and less now and nowadays it's people
could come up with something new but
then it was just kind of like a bunch of
musicians in a room trying to work it
out experimenting I do like this to what
Steve was saying about I think it was
Steve that's saying that we say Sabbath
the priests but there's a lot that
happened in-between because you're
missing half the story of metal without
these early bands I think that's
completely right yeah I like that yeah
so I hope I answered the question yeah
and you're not just missing a story like
a you know bit of history I mean this is
another thing that's brought up by this
question you're missing an opportunity
for you might call it engagement of your
own musical sensibilities and
development it'd be sort of like if
somebody who's like well you know I like
funk but there's James Brown that's all
I really need to listen to okay no
that's a great point yeah that's a great
point it'd be great if you want to sound
like James Brown and probably reinvent a
lot of wheels you know coming on for
that but I imagine if you were gonna try
to do things that sounded like heavy
metal and you're gonna say I don't
really need to listen to Motorhead or
you know actually we have this happening
in all sorts of fields including my own
philosophy where people are like I don't
need to like bother with all this
previous stuff you know I'll just like
you know I'm going to be original and
then you know quite often originality
it's it's you know tough to achieve well
and make it a little overrated you know
I I want to I want to chime in on this
important yeah you know we have we have
this thing with like philosophers and
musicians that want to be they wear this
badge of honor of I'm self-taught Oh
yeah here's the thing everybody
self-taught unless you were born in a
bubble and never heard music and was
given a guitar and you invented music by
yourself if you've heard music okay if
you've ever listened to albums it's
already in there and and whether you go
on YouTube and somebody shows you chords
and scales or the person's physically in
the room with you is that is that a
difference are you self-taught if the
person's of talking-head on your
computer screen but here's the thing why
we're all self-taught you can take 30
years of lessons but if you write albums
and improvise well you've done that
yourself your teacher can't do that
your teacher can it's like language
right we all have our own way of
speaking but we all know the alphabet
and we all know what a verb is we don't
all speak the same yeah
we're something that's a good philosophy
there's philosophers what was the one
that we were talking about with a patina
of it that said don't read philosophy
just come up with your own and he had
all kinds of holes in this thing because
he didn't learn to think well you say
you're saying that some of his students
want to want to do that and that's a
mistake right people who don't want to
study logic because his criticism is
like well okay go ahead don't don't do
that then just stick to practice and
ethics and then as soon as somebody like
hoodwinks you with a bad argument you're
gonna kind of wish you study the logic
part instead it's sort of like somebody
who's like you know oh I'll learn guitar
but I'll finger things any way that I
want to whatever feels best to me and
then suddenly they realize that they
can't make the transitions that they
need to make yeah but like you know just
the fact that you remember guy dragging
I'm self-taught you know I learned every
Jeff Jimmy Page so like oh so you're
pretty much exactly you're playing with
Jimmy Page you're not actually unique
you've learned from records whether
whether you go into town and somebody
shows you a b7 chord you you know you
can't argue it's a badge of honor I
think in both of our fields right like
we don't need to know the class I have
my own ideas but not there is also sort
of a corresponding vise on the other
side which is the name dropping
right I am i studied with so-and-so so
I'm you know really really great and
writing some writing somebody else's
coattails right and there are some
people who are just like pure imitators
of other people and and you know when
they when they're just doing that I'm
cool with it it provided they don't like
have pretensions not they're doing
something better like I would actually I
love listening to good tribute bands
that just are they're not about trying
to like you know prove anything I just
want to sell my kissed or Judas Priest
or whoever you know and play around with
the music there's one other question I I
don't want to go too far over time but
there's a good discussion going on here
about religion Arashi asked how do you
trace the relation of early heavy metal
to religion and then Carl says that's a
great question maybe more of a
sociological question than a musical one
but definitely relevant I think about
the changing values coming out of the
50s into the 60s where they ended up
coming into the 70s the Kenan says
religions definitely had a significant
influence on various genres quite a bit
later than the 70s and that that's quite
correct folk metal has heaps of
religious influence and we could go on
and you know I mean this is something
that comes up with Black Sabbath of
course you know geezer butler has been a
practicing Catholic his entire life and
you know Sabbath had a lot of focus on
the occult and then I majored major
theme in heavy metal you know so if you
think about like the early songs is he
glorifying you know as the big you know
moral what do we call this when people
get all worked up about things like
Geraldo with his show in the 80s moral
panics right and those are all devil
worshippers right Black Sabbath was
never doing that as a matter of fact
usually when the devil shows up in the
songs it's a problem beautiful things of
God off kilter and you want to get the
hell out of there as quickly as as
possible you know oh no please God help
me the early contributors so like Alice
Cooper and we brought him up before
comes out of a a religious background
definitely rebelling against a very
smart guy subverting things I think
there was a good bit of you know sort of
sort of like playing around with these
themes definitely hostile to let's call
it the old-time religion which was
usually a distortion of you know
Christian teachings tied in with all
sorts of you know political and social
commitments anyway that a lot of people
were reacting against I don't think you
can say that there's a lot of religious
elements to say deep purple or Uriah
Heep or Bungie or Judas Priest you know
I think that in a lot of bands it takes
kind of kind of a back seat and if we're
talking about the early period I would
say that maybe you know Black Sabbath
and you know little bits and pieces of
other bands kind of tie into that and
you can say that at most there's a
reaction against the religiosity of the
time I mean it's really in the 1980s
where this moral panic occurs and people
are finding Satanists everywhere where
they are - that is right I mean my mom
watched the Geraldo special I don't
remember when that aired and then she
wanted to like take all of our albums
away you know because she was worried we
were to become devil worshippers and
then there I mean there were bands that
were were making stuff like that really
part of their themes and Arash brings up
you know like Ozzy and do Black Sabbath
and then Iron Maiden's number the piece
of course again Iron Maiden's number of
the beast when you listen to the song
it's a problem that The Devil's around
right
it's not about devil worship it's like
let's get away from this terrible force
that's gonna do something to me so it's
more horror really than anything else
that's a great I just want to say that
uh that you know even back in the day
like parents would hear a line from the
song and it would have the devil or yeah
and they would say the mother glorifying
oh yeah well it goes back to what you
always say get back to me when you've
read the text oh yeah you know and and
we were just joking on DNA about spinal
tap you know they had Christmas with the
devil but that was a parity sign you
know there's sort of playing with it I
mean I think in the 80s we can talk
about say bands like Jenna but even
venom you know in interviews they're
like yeah you know not really totally
into this or you know we're playing
around on this and then other bands
later on became much more interested in
that and it's hard to think of bands
that really like made it massively big
it's usually within genres right that
that became we can also talk about
Christian which way yeah and that's so
that's the one go-to band in the
eighties and they weren't particularly
good over there so the second tier you
know you don't think they could put
tunes together there was something about
like trying to make it conform to a
particular ideology that didn't work
very well III don't I think you can say
that metal like most other things can
take on a lot of different other flavors
components but there's some that just
don't work with it you know I have a
question for you Greg this is a good one
for you okay I don't have a deep
understanding of Christianity but would
you say the lyrics would you say
stripers lyrics were correct or were
they kind of oh I don't know I mean it's
been I didn't I haven't listened to them
since the eighties yeah I listened to
awful in god we trust' and it was kind
of Pro Christ but I was like it was like
kind of like Iron Maiden with their
history lessons I don't know if they're
always trouble yeah exactly you wouldn't
want to like understand the Battle of
Britain through the lens of Aces High
right or or what's a song where humans
and dinosaurs lived lived at the same
time on the planet well that's on Oh
quest for fire yeah you know and and I
like her
and they had they had an album that I
thought it was really cool called at war
with Satan and I mean now we're like
totally into like you know telling old
war stories and stuff like that but I
when I got that that album on tape from
a friend of mine I was like wait so
there's like there's more than two sides
here this guy is like positioning
himself as being is totally against God
but he's also against Satan it's kind of
interesting here you know but you know
that I didn't I didn't stick with this
you could say all right yeah oh so go
ahead so yeah do another one
well let's see what we've got
I think we can take one more question
and then we should we should probably
wrap up there's some questions here
about about vocals
here's one from Carl are there any great
current really heavy heavy metal bands
that don't use the Cookie Monster vocal
style that's your point what that is but
it has to say that's the most
off-putting elements because it just
makes me laugh and so Canada's right
look at traditional heavy metal or power
metal and there is a thing called the
new wave of traditional heavy metal but
another thing I'll say too is that many
of the big old bands are out there still
touring and still like some of them are
still putting out new good stuff Saxon
is a great example they have been
consistently churning out albums they
tour we've seen them twice just in the
last three four years and they put on an
amazing show yeah Judas Priest of course
is still out there touring we saw Uriah
Heep recently and they have put I mean
2016 I think is their latest album but
if there's new stuff on it and and some
of this really great stuff so you do
have like the newer bands that are doing
you know I would say you know power
metal that that's that's right I would
say you know if you're in of the genres
I like doom metal you know the stuff
that sounds like early Sabbath or
pentagram like you know electric wizard
or orchid or bands like that and they're
not doing I'm assuming the Cookie
Monster thing is the growling thing I
mustered yeah well picture cookie
monsters
like I mean that's literal it's it's the
I mean I think and a lot of that doom
stuff I'll mention too is very melodic
as well so that that's that's pretty you
know that's pretty good but you can
listen to the newer stuff by older bands
a lot of them are quite fertile right
now where we're kind of in a renaissance
time for not only do we have a lot of
really good newer bands but the older
bands that have managed to like not kill
themselves with drug abuse or other
crazy stuff are doing cool stuff you
know well the the newer bands that are
the kind of a renaissance to like let's
say the mid 80's melodic rock what they
call eel AOR that's coming out of Sweden
and these singers are fantastic I mean
bands like a work of art and but like I
don't know if we consider that metal I
mean you know like AOR like Dokken or
something Dawkins metal yeah so it's but
that's a lot it gets very many choruses
I would say a lot of these bands they're
not Chicago like you know like the Peter
Cetera eighties Chicago that's AOR
without being metal yeah
like Europe the van Europe okay yeah
yeah super melodic but definitely heavy
guitars and shred solos and but like you
know there's a lot of bands that are you
know these people in their 20s and 30s
that are writing great melodic rock now
it's not new it's like a throwback but
it is brand new bands with brand new
material paying homage to these you know
bands like doc and bands that did have
these melodies and these big choruses
which you know even by the time Bon Jovi
did new jersey they got pretty rock and
roll you know it was kind of made me
call it like glam first one thing I'll
say about Donkin that I found out when I
was doing research quite quite a ways
back I didn't know is Don Dokken
actually really got his start doing
stuff with the scorpions interestingly
enough and yeah I mean who would write
I'm an American guy I'm not quite sure
where George Lynch you know came up from
as well because I think for the early
doc and son George Lynch right I
but I think that you can see when once
you realize that dock and hand these
connections to the Scorpions I think a
lot of things fall into place
you know in terms of like again Rudolf
Shankar master songwriter right freight
dogs I think so this is kind of a good
thing to maybe go out on and here's an
idea just to like throw out there there
there is a kind of sense of like we're
we're inventing something new trying out
new sounds but I think that like with
most other music genres there's also a
kind of apprenticeship thing going on as
well and it can be apprentice thing at a
distance like you you know you hear
somebody's you know you play along with
their records and you're in your you
know room and try to like learn all the
lakes and riffs and stuff like that I
think that's that's that's part of it
that acquiring that Sensibility
and so the early to go back to this the
early heavy metal stuff winds up being
so influential in part because there's
such a rich musical scene going on and
you know you didn't have to be in
Britain to pick up on it I mean it was
cool if you could see Sabbath life I
mean I would have been like a little
baby it's got I don't know I think
you're a little bit younger so any
months I mean you could have been
conceived at a Santa thing you know to
be able to participate in it the fact
that we did have the records and then
the tapes and the possibility of like
you know actually seeing a lot of these
bands they were broadcast on TV
sometimes they'd actually get radio play
I think though that's a really important
theme and so you know we're going to do
more of these and we'll pick up on a
whole bunch of other you know topics
themes questions problems sometimes
it'll probably be a little bit more
philosophically oriented sometimes a
little bit more history oriented I want
to thank Scotford for coming on is
really great to have somebody who I can
actually tap as any practicing musician
so I'm not just you know
speculating no it's my pleasure thanks
for I'd love to do this I mean if you
this is great great topic
yeah so thanks everybody for showing up
for this inaugural session and yeah Karl
says we can talk about more about hair
you certainly do that that could be a
theme that you get to all right so I'm
gonna wish everybody a whatever it is
where you're in the world I know we've
got you know one person here from South
Africa so it's probably going on evening
there good afternoon to everybody here
in this Hemisphere and we'll pick up
with this again next month